ياخر ويا تتواصل الاحتجاجات في العراق ضد
سياسه رئيس الحكومه نور المالكي في وقت
تستمر فيه غود الاطراف المختلفه الراميه
لتهدئه الموقف في ظل حاله من الترقب لجلسه
البرلمان المقرره
[موسيقى]
الاحد
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من زاويتين هل
في الساحه العراقيه الان ما يمكن ان يطلق
عليه الطرف الثالث القادره على الوصول لحل
وسط وفي ظل جهود سياسيه متواصله واحتجاجات
في الشارع لم تتوقف ايهما يمكنه تطبيع
الاخر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لصالحه
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم الى حلقه جديده من
برنامج ما وراء
الخبر تتجه الانظار في العراق الى جلسه
متوقعه للبرلمان صباح الاحد لعلها تاتي
بجديد يخفف من حده الازمه السياسيه
الحاليه في البلاد حيث تتواصل الاحتجاجات
ضد سياسات رئيس الحكومه نوري المالكي
المتهم من قبل المتظاهرين بممارسه سياسات
التهميش والاقصاء ورغم ان بعض الجهود
السياسيه تبدل حاليا الا ان حركه الشارع
تبدو اسرع حيث يتسع نطاق المظاهرات
والاعتصامات
باتت بدايه الازمه الراهنه في العراق
معلومه للجميع لكن لا احد الى حد الان على
الاقل بوسعه الجزم بما ستنتهي عليه اياما
بعد امتداد الاحتجاجات الجماهيريه الى
مناطق عده في بلاد الرافدين اتجهت الانظار
الى النخب السياسيه بحثا عن عن حل ما
للتوتر القائم من وجهه نظر قاده القائمه
العراقيه لا حل سوى في استقاله المالك
وتشكيل حكومه انتقاليه بديله تؤمن تسيير
شؤون الدوله واجراء انتخابات مبكره سقف
عال في الطرح لم تبلغه بعد اطراف اخرى مثل
الحزب الاسلامي والتيار الصدري والتحالف
الكردستاني قاسم العراقيه مسانده التحركات
الاحتجاجيه والمطالبه باجراءات سريعه
للاستجابه لمطالبها
قدره
الهرميه عقدها الاحد بدعوه من رئيس مجلس
النواب اسامه النجيفي على تحصيل النصاب
اللازم لعقدها فضلا عن التصويت بالاغلبيه
المطلقه الممثله في
163 نائبا لفائده حل الحكومه والبرلمان
تمهيدا الانتخابات المبكره مع ذلك بدت
ملفته تسريبات تنتظر التاكيد النهائيه
قالت ان رئيس الوزراء العراق نور المالك
الذي امر القوات العراقيه بعدم الانجرار
الى مواجهه المتظاهرين وتحدث عن مساع
محليه واقليميه لتقويض العمليه السياسيه
في البلاد قد يطرح بدوره في اليومين
القادمين طلبا لحل الحكومه والبرلمان مما
يمهد الانتخابات مبكره توافق ظاهري في
التلويح بصندوق الاقتراع فيصلا بين
الفرقاء السياسيين يخفي وراءه في الحقيقه
حسابات ورهانات متناقضه خبرها الشارع الع
طويلا في تجاذبات سابقه تضمنت فكره سحب
الثقه من حكومه المالك دون ان تتمكن من
ذلك ودون ان يقع ايضا نزع فتين الاسباب
العميقه للاحتقان الحالي اسباب سير التيار
الصدري وفودا الى عدد من مدن ومحافظات
العراق لتوثيقها والتحاور مع المعنيين بها
قبل نقلها الى الحكومه فيما بدا محاوله
اخيره لراب الصدع قبل المرور الى خيارات
بديله تدخل العراق في مرحله غير
مسبوقه معنا في هذه الحلقه من الرمادي
الدكتور احمد العلواني عضو مجلس النواب عن
القائمه العراقيه ومن بغداد الدكتوره حنان
الفتلاوي عضو مجلس النواب عن ائتلاف دوله
القانون اهلا بضيفي نبدا بالدكتوره حنان
الفتلاوي دكتوره فتلاوي هل تعتقدين بان في
ظل الازمه الحاليه في العراق هناك طرف
ثالث يمكن ان يلعب دور الوسيط
بكفاءه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مؤكد يفترض
ان يكون هناك طرف ينقل المطالب المشروعه
والتي تتعلق بصلاحيات الحكومه للحكومه
لتقوم بتبني ما يخص صلاحياتها وعلى مجلس
النواب ان يتحمل مسؤوليتها والسلطه
القضائيه انا لا احبذ ان يكون طرف خارجي
نعم من الاطراف الداخليه الاطراف المشتركه
بالعمليه السياسيه من الممكن ان تكون جهه
تتبنى نقل مطالب المتظاهرين ما كان منها
مشروعا لاصاله للحكومه والحكومه مستعده
لسماع المطالب المشروعه بعيدا عن الشعارات
الطائفيه وبعيدا عن شعارات حزب البع التي
رفعت والاعلام التي رفعت وكل هذه المسائل
بعيدا عنها بعض المواطنين بالفعل لديهم
مطالب مشروعه يفترض ان تؤخذ و يتم التعامل
معها بجديه اما الدعوات الطائفيه والتي
تدعو الى حرب طائفيه وتاجي الوضع في
العراق تمهيدا لتقسيمه وبدفع من جهات
خارجيه مؤكد هذه الدعوات مرفوضه اليوم
يعني البلد تجاوز الازمه تجاوز المشكله
طافيه لا اسمح لي يعني تقريبا الكل مجمع
على انه لا مكان لاعطاء اي بعد طائفي
للتحرك الحاليه ولكن بالنسبه لكم على
الاقل هل تعتقدون ولو بالاسم ان هناك طرف
مازال الان على مسافه واحده ان امكن بين
الغاضبين وبين حكومه السيد المالكي ويمكن
ان يلعب
دورا يعني هناك من يحاول ان يجعل المساله
وكانها بين السيد المالكي وبين المتظاهرين
القضيه ليست بهذا الشكل اخي اولا القضيه
فيها ابعاد تتعلق بمجلس النواب رئيس مجلس
النواب اليوم اصبح طرف من المشكله يتهرب
من مسؤولياته كثير من القضايا التي يطلبها
المتظاهرين لا علاقه للحكومه بها قانون
العفو قانون اجتثاث البعث وقانون اربعه
رهاب كلها قضايا متعلقه بمجلس النواب مجلس
النواب تنصل عن مسؤولياته يقف على المنصات
ويخطب ويحفز ويؤجج طائفيا ويصيح الله اكبر
و جينا للحرب وهذه الشعارات الصداميه ترفع
هنا وهناك مجلس النواب ترك مسؤولياتها
بالتالي القضيه ليست حكومه وشعب قضيه
منهجين اليوم الشارع الشيعي متاهب متا
متحفز لانه ما اثير من خطابات ودعوات هي
ليست انت تقول الكل مجمع على اخراجها من
طابعها الطائفي هذا الكلام غير دقيق اخي
حينما يسب الشيعه ويتهمون بانهم خنازير
وعملاء يران واولاد الزنا وغيرها وكل هذه
الشعارات التي رفعت حينما ترفع صور
اردوغان وترفع صور صدام حسين
ويرفع ط يفترض يفترض دكتوره فلتاو فتلاوي
عفوا حتى لو رفعت هذه الشعارات من قبل
البعض مسؤوليه الطبقه الس السياسيه هو
انضاج هذه الشعارات وعدم الانجرار ورائها
بالطبع في كل تحركات شعبيه توجد اصوات
نشاز هنا وهناك لكن التوجه العام ليس
طائفيا على الاقل كما يبدو لحد الان وهنا
اسال السيد العلواني السيد العلواني هل
يمكن لمجلس النواب الذي اشرت اليه قبل
قليل الدكتوره فتلاوي ان يلعب دور هذا
الطرف الثالث وان يكون ساحه لاداره
الخلافات
الان شكرا جزيلا
بدايه بس تعقيب على كلام الاخت حنان حول
انه تم سب الشيعه بالمظاهرات و هي المقصود
انا انا اتحداك واتحدى اي شخص يثبت هذا
الفيلم الفيلم موجود على قناه الجزيره انا
تكلمت عن ابناء الانبار عندنا كم شخص من
الانبار تكلمت عنهم عملاء خانوا العراق
وخانوا السنه والشيعه وخانوا الوطن هؤلاء
قرده وخنازير اقول هالمره المليون كل شخص
يخون بلده هو قرد اقل ما يصب انه قرد
خنزير انا لم اسب احد ولم اطعم بشرف احد
واما هذه الشعارات طائفيه ودعم اقليمي هذه
اكاذيب جوز منها يا جماعه والله الناس
تعرف شكو ماكو كفى اكاذيب كفى تلاعب
بمشاعر الناس هل يعقل ان شخص معمم وملتحي
يكذب على الناس من اجل تكسب طائفي يعني
ويعتقدون مؤتمرات صحفيه طيب اذا عندكم ه
هذا الفيلم وهذا الشريط اعرضوه على شاشات
التلفاز حتى الناس تعرف من هو الصادق ومن
هو الكاذب كفى لعب مشاعر الناس يا سيدتي
عيب علينا نصل لمرحله نستغل مشاعر الناس
البريئه اذا الان انت اوضحت الصوره لا
اسمح لي انت اوضحت الصوره بالنسبه
للدكتوره فتلاوي حتى نظل في في صلب موضوع
الحلقه نحن نتحدث في هذا الجزء قبل الفاصل
عما اذا كان يوجد في العراق الان طرف يمكن
ان يلعب دور الوسط او ان مجلس النواب مثل
ما اشارت الدكتوره يمكن ان يكون ساحه لهذا
الموضوع سيدي الكريم مجلس النواب ليس من
حقه ان يشرع قوانين السيد المالكي السنه
الماضيه اقام دعوه المحكمه الاتحاديه
وصدرت له قرار لا يمكن لمجلس النواب بشرع
قانون لا مقترح ولا مشروع قوانين تثم
الحكومه قانون العفو العام درج على جدول
الاعمال اكثر من مره لكن الاخوه في دوله
القانون هم انسحب وخل بال النصاب مشاريع
القوانين الكره في ملعب الحكومه ثم مطالب
ابناء الانبار وغيرها ليست مستحيله قس من
كلها متعلقه بعمل حكومه والسيد المالكي
عندما اخت تقول تكلم يعني تعان بايجابيه
وغيره ومطالب هي قالت مشروعه لماذا يقول
انها فقاع نتنا هل هذا اسلوب مؤدب يليق
برئيس وزراء يتكلم مع ابناء شعبه ثم هل كل
ه الملايين اللي خرجت يعقل كلهم بعثيون هل
يعقل انهم كلهم
قاعده دوله
خارجيه هو اشار في البدايه اشار في
البدايه اسمح لي فقط هو اشار في البدايه
لهذه المفردات التي تقولها الان ولكن بدا
في خطابه الثاني او في كلامه الثاني وكانه
هدا نوعا ما من غلوه هذا الخطاب كما يتهمه
البعض السبب السبب ان هذه الانتفاضه
انتفاضه مسلحه عفوا سلميه وتحترم الدستور
والدليل لكونها سم
جءتنا وفود من البصره والناصريه والنجف
وكربلاء ايمان منهم ان هذه التظاهر هذا حق
مشروكه فله الدستور اما صور اردوغان
واعلام قطر والسعوديه والله اكذوبه سئمنا
منها انا لدي معلومات ان الجهاد في بغداد
طبعت صور لصدام حسين ورموز النظام السابق
واعلام ابو النجمات ولديهم ناس مدسوس في
داخل مظاهرات حتى تحرف هذه المظاهرات
النبيله الشريفه عن هدف النبيل وقضيه عزه
دوري عزه الدوري كان 40 سنه بالدوله ما
سوى شي الان مع مقوله رجل ما ععد موجود ما
موجود يطلع ولا يت المظاهرات احنا ما
يشرفنا اي شخص يتبنى هذه المظاهرات هذه
المظاهرات تبناها ابناء الانبار بشيوخ
وشبابها وعلمائها ومثقفيها لا هناك لا
علام ولا شعارات طائفيه ولا اي صور لاي ش
واضح واضح فيما يتعلق ب مره اخرى انا اعود
ولكن لا احد من الضيفين الكريمين اعطاني
ولو راس خيط لطرف ثالث او حتى اسم او حتى
شخصيه او تيار مره اخرى اعود للدكتوره
حنان مثلا على سبيل المثال السيد مقتدى
الصدر والتيار الصدري ايه هل يمكن له ان
ان يلعب هذا الدور باعتباره ابدا نوع من
التعاطف مع المطالب الشعبيه وغير محسوب
على الصف الاخر على الاقل للاسف طائفيا
ونحن ناسف لهذا التصنيف الذي يعتمد احياان
بدايه دعني ارد على ضيفك الكريم ومن ثم
اعود للسيد مقتدى
الصرف عن اللغه التي يتحدث بها النائب
يؤسفني ان النائب يبدو تعود على لغه
السباب وانا اقول كل ناء بما فيه ينضح
السباب والشتم لا يليق بي ولا يليق به سب
وشتم طائفه محترمه ولدينا القرص وانا اسال
النائب هل ينفي انه قال لن نقف الا بتحرير
العراق لن نقف الا في في طهران انا لا لا
افهم كيف يرضى على نفسه ان يسب عراقي سواء
كان شيعيا ام سنيا انت قلت خنازير ابناء
خنازير ان كنت تقصد الشيعه او كنت تقصد
سنه من الانبار لا يليق بك وانت نائب ممثل
للشعب يفترض ان يكون كلامك موزون الامام
علي يقول يا ليت لي رقبه البعير حتى لا
يخرج مني كلام اندم عليه واسي فيه لطائفه
محترمه او لشخص محترم هذا من جانب الجانب
الاخر شعارات الطائفيه ليست بعيده اليوم
مصوره وموجوده لافتات تقول يا اولاد الزنا
لن اخرجوا المعتقلين يا اولاد الزنا كذا
هذه غير مقبوله لا من الانبار ولا من صلاح
الدين ولا من الموصل نقول بلد واحد من
لديه مشاكل ياتي لديكم اطراف في الحكومه
وزير الماليه وزير وزاره سياديه النواب
اليوم العلواني وغير العلواني يقفون على
المنصات يهتفون وهم لا يحضرون جلسات مجلس
النواب حقوق المتين ومطالب المتظاهرين
كثير منها في قوانين يجلس في مجلس النواب
ويشرع القوان
اسحي من البدايه البدايه سالت سؤا واحدا
يتيما لا حضرتك ولا حضره السيد العلواني
رد لي عليه هل يوجد اعيدها للمره الخامسه
ه هل يوجد طرف في العراق يمكن ان يلعب
دورا توفيقيه سؤال بسيط لا احد منكم رد
عليه يعني اخي الكريم انا سارد عليك انا
سارد عليك اي شخص بغض النظر كائنا من يكون
اليوم سواء من المتظاهرين او من المسؤولين
او من مجلس النواب ياتي بمطالب المتظاهرين
ويجلس مع الاطراف الحكومه والبرلمان
والسلطه القضائيه ما كان ضمن اختصاص
الحكومه الحكومه ستتعامل معه بشكل ايجابي
ما كان ضمن اختصاص مجلس النواب يؤخذ لمجلس
النواب يتولى مسؤولياته ما كان ضمن السلطه
القضائيه السلطه القضائيه تتحمل مسؤوليتها
السيد مقتضى الصدر ممكن ان يلعب دورا ولكن
عليك ان لا تنسى ان السيد مقتضى الصدر جزء
من الحكومه لديه مجموعه من الوزارات ست
وزارات في الحكومه العراقيه الحاليه
وبالتالي هو ليس طرف محايدا الاخوه في
العراقيه ايضا جزء من الحكومه من يريد ان
يجعل نفسه طرفا في الخلاف بين المتظاهرين
وبين الحكومه يفترض ان يكون خارج اللعبه
السياسيه من غير المنطقي انا عندي اغلبيه
في مجلس النواب واذهب مع المتظاهرين
اتظاهر يا اخي اجلس في مجلس النواب وحل
مشاكلك وشرع قوانينك يا وزراء العراقيه
حلوا مشاكلكم هل لا توجد مشاكل اليوم في
وزاره التربيه ام لا توجد مشاكل في وزاره
الزراعه ام وزاره الماليه خاليه من
المشاكل ادوا واجباتكم في وزارتكم وبتالي
تحقق مطالب
مته
الحال نعم اذا في هذه الحاله دكتوره انت
تعتبرين انه حتى السيد مقتدى الصدر هناك
حد ادنى من المسؤوليه والتضامن الحكومي في
هذه الحاله دكتور علواني سؤالي واضح
وارجوك لا تقول لي ساعود لتوضيح ما قالته
الدكتوره رجاء اغلقنا
القوسين هل هناك طرف يمكن ان يلعب دور
الان في هذه الازمه
الحاليه دور توفيقي اقصد طبعا
سيدي الكريم المطالب التي قدمت من
المتظاهرين واضحه لا لبس فيها الكره الان
في ملعب الحكومه اما محاوله تجديده
الملفات هنا وهنا هذا ليس في مصلحه احد
انا ما اعرف الاخوه بدوره القانون ليش
التعنت وكنا ما نحكي على الحكومه يعني ما
ادري يعني هم واحد كفر الله جل وعلا همه
هيك ماكو داع يعني الفوقيه
الزايده المتظاهرون قدموا مطالب لا يس
هناك وسيط لان لا عندنا مفاوضات تشكيل
حكومه ولا هم يحزنون مطالب واضحه الحكومه
تنفذها المعتصمين كل من يذهب الى شانه اما
في غياب
الاستجابه اعطاء اذن صماء وتكلم بالفاظ
نابيه امام ناس شرفاء خدم العراق
والوطن تريد يعني بهالطريقه هذه لا يمكن
تحل الامور وال المتظاهرون قالوا بالحرف
الواحد لا انا المتظاهرون قالوا لن نتنازل
عن حرف واحد 13 مطلب على الحكومه ان
تنفذها هؤلاء عراقيون مواطنون من الدرجه
الاولى ليست هناك لا اجنده لا اقليميه لا
اتصالات دوليه مثل ما كذب البعض احدهم
يتكلم دعم اسرائيلي طايح الحظ هو يعني
معقوله وصلت السذاجه الى هذا المستوى
الرذيل غسان عطيه قبل يومين رجل معروف رجل
لبرالي رجل عراقي جاء للتظاهر قال لجد لا
لا جهات اقليميه وجد ابناء عشائر ناس
شرفاء ناس وطنيون مطالبهم وطنيه و هو الان
واضح الان واضح سيد علواني واضح الان انه
الاعتصامات والتظاهرات متواصله الجهود
السياسيه تتواصل بشكل او باخر بغض النظر
عن درجه النجاعه والكفاءه في التوسط نريد
ان نعرف بعد الفاصل الى اي مدى يمكن ان
يتغلب هذا المنحى او ذاك ل عوده بعد هذا
الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه الجاريه حاليا في العراق
وهذا السير او السباق بين الجهود السياسيه
وبين امكانيه تواصل الاحتجاجات دكتوره
حنان
فتلاوي ماذا ترجح فيما يتعلق
بمستقبل هذه الاحتجاجات مع استمرار بعض
المساعي
السياسيه
طبعا والله انا اشعر اني اخطات خطا كبير
لا يليق بي ان اجلس في جلسه مع نائب يتلفظ
بالفاظ يشاهده
الملاين لياقات الكلام غير مقبوله هذا من
جانه رد عليه يا دكتوره انت قلتي كلام وهو
رد عليه وهو قال كلام وانت رديت عليه يعني
يفت يفترض فيكم انت ما شاء الله ما شاء
الله انت من النخبه السياسيه في البلد
ونواب يعني واحد واح
انا معر هذا السجال اغلق يعني رجاء لو
تكرمت لو تكرمت اسمحلي او اوكي خليني ارد
على سؤالك خليني ارد على سؤالك اساسا انا
ما استخدمت اي لفظه اي لفظه نابيه او
جارحه لم استخدم تسجيل عندك اثنين احنا
طرحنا خيارات الموجوده اربعه لا غير لا
يوجد غيرها اما ان نتحدث نذهب الى حرب
طائفيه وهذا ما لا نريد الشارع الشيعي
متاهب والشارع السني متاهب كل له شارعه
وكل متشنج وكل يعتقد انه هو صاحب الحق هذا
لا يخدم الشيعه ولا يخدم السنه وبالتالي
هذا يحقق اجدات خارجيه هناك من يريد ان
يدخل العراق في حرب طائفيه هذا الخيار لا
نريده ولا نفكر به ولا ندعو له الخيار
الاخر ان ينقسم العراق ويتقسم الى اقاليم
سنيه وشيع وكرديه وهذا يبدو ان بعض الاخوه
الان لديهم مطالبات بهذا الاتجاه هذا
الخيار ايضا لا نريده لانه ايضا مقدمه
لتجزئة وهذا يخدم مصالح دول اخرى ومسعى
لجهات اخرى خيارين غير مقبولين بقي خيارين
الخيار الاول اما ان نجلس حوار وتجلس
السلطات الثلاث تشريعيه تنفيذيه قضائيه
تتحمل مسؤولياتها و بجلسه علنيه ومكاشفة
وغير قادر على حل المشاكل والحكومه غير
قادره على حل المشاكل اذا البرلمان
والحكومه غير مرضيين الان نذهب الى
انتخابات مبكره عل وعسى ان تاتي حكومه
جديده وبرلمان جديد فيه وجوه اخرى
وبالتالي المواطن يحقق ما يريده هذه
الخيارات الاربعه لا خامسه لها اما
انتخابات مبكره حل البرلمان وحل الحكومه
او نجلس نتحاور ويتحمل كل مسؤوليته او
نذهب الى حرب طائفيه او نذهب الى اقاليم
وتقسيم البلد اما ان ان نترك الامور ونرفع
شعارات عامه اليوم يتحدثون عن الخدمات اخي
لماذا تعيد المحافظات موازناتها من حاسب
محافظ الموصل على اعاده 70% من موازنته
الى الماليه لا ينفقها على خدمات
المواطنين وناتي ونتحدث يقف في وسط
المتظاهرين ويرفع شعارات لمن لا يحاسب
نفسه من حاسب نائب رئيس الوزراء لشؤون
الخدمات وهو المسؤول عن خدمات المواطنين
لماذا لا يحاسب الوزراء المتلك الذين لا
يؤدون واجبات اذا على الجميع ان يتحمل
مسؤوليته نحن قلناها ونقولها اليوم لا
توجد سوى هذه الاربع خيارات على الاخوه ان
يقرروا اي خيار يريدون الحرب الطائفيه نعم
الشارع مستعد لها انخل الشار شراه واحده
قد تدخلنا في حرب لن تنتهي لنس السيد احمد
علواني اربع خيارات واضحه بتقديرك الى اين
يمكن ان تسير
الامور انا بس يعني الاخت حنان لا تصير
عصبيه زايد ما يستوجب الامر العصبيه
ارجو ارجو ارجوك هي اغلقت القوس انت اغل
انت اغلق معها الله ينورك انت اغلق معها
الله ينورك تفضل سيدي تفضل سيدي الكريم
سيدي الكريم من وقف بوجه الحرب الطائفيه
هم نحن نحن من قاتل الارهاب والتكفير ونحن
من كنا صمام امان لد ه الفتنه الطائفيه
معروف من هو اشعل الفتنه الطائفيه نعوذ
بالله يعني حقيقه هذا يعني هذا الكلام يجب
ان لا تتلفظ به هذه دعوات لحرب طائفيه
نعوذ بالله منها تاكل الاخضر واليابس
لازال هناك فرصه لحوار يعني هي القضيه
حقوق انسان احنا ما نريد خدمات خدمات لا
خدمات لا بطاقه تامينيه الان هناك امتعاض
من ما يحصل في السجون هل ينكر ما يحصل من
اغتصاب وتعذيب واهانه ويعني ب انتقائيه
واربع ارهاب وغيرها هذه اللي خلت الناس
تخرج بالملايين تعبر عن رفضها لهذا النهج
الخاطئ محاوله اقصاء مكون ومعاملته
مواطنين من الدرجه الثانيه هذا ما نرتضيه
اما قضيه الخدمات والميزانيه هذا لم يتكلم
عنها احد هذه قضيه نحن احرص على وحده
العراق من غيرنا اما قضيه المطالبه
للاقاليم طيب اذا سياسه اقصائيه انت تلغي
الناس تذبحهم على الهويه و تمنع كل شي
تسوي الناس في عروقها دماء وليس ماء ا اذا
ا اذا يبقى اذا يبقى اذا يبقى الخياران
سيد علواني يبقى الخياران اما حوار بين
السلطات الثلاث او الذهاب الى الانتخابات
لماذا لا تدفع في اتجاه واضح في احد هذين
الخين احنا بالنسبه لنا استاذ محمد الاخت
تكلمت خياره الاوليه التقسيم والحرب
الطائفيه نحن نقف بوجه هذين الخيارين
انتهينا من الحرب الطائفيه وانقسام العراق
بالنسبه للخيار البقين نعوذ بالله نحن نحن
من دافع عن وحده العراق مو غيرنا اما قضيه
الحوار هذه كذبه لا يمكن لاحد يصدقها بعد
شبعنا حوارات
ومبادرات واتفاقيات وقعت بالقلم الاحمر ول
يتم التزام بها الحل الاثل هو السيد
المالكي يحترم نفسه ويقدم استقاله لان
مصير العراق اهم مني ومن المالكي ومن كل
العناوين المشكله ليست في البرلمان
المشكله في الحكومه بالتحديد شخص رئيس
الوزراء كل مشكله كل قضيه في العراق هي
عباره عن مشكله لا هناك احترام لا للشراكه
لا حقوق الانسان لا كرامه الناس لا يمكن
تقييم الامور هكذا وه لماذا لماذا عدم
الذها لماذا عدم الذهاب الى انتخابات عامه
وانته الامر انتخابات عامه
لماذا انتخابات عامه والبرلمان موجود وحكم
موجوده العله في شخص اداره الدوله من قبل
رئيس الوزراء هذه هي المشكله والقضيه ليست
العراقيه فقط التيار الصدري يديه ملاحظات
على السيد المالكي التحالف الكردستاني
الاحرار فقط دوله القانون هم من تشبث
بالسيد المالكي والعراق انا اقول لك لا
يمكن ان نسمح ان يرتهن مصير البلد
ومقدراته بشخص واحد طيب لا يمكن ه
الدكتاتوريه الزايده وه النرجسيه وكانما
الله ما خلق م المالكي ما يصير هكذا
الامور تدار نتكلم عن حقوق اهلنا طائفيين
نتكلم حقوق مواطنينا اجنده اقليميه وما
ادري ايش الناس واعيه والناس تعرف والناس
يقرر ذلك شكرا لك شكرا لك الدكتور احمد
العلواني عضو مجلس النواب عن القائمه
العراقيه شكرا ايضا من بغداد للدكتوره
حنان الفتلاوي عضو مجلس النواب عن ائتلاف
دوله القانون بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ان